Charlie did you hear he was on The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert that's where
you were last night that was what I was
did we found out what's making him tick
since the last time we had John here he
had heart surgery I'd be wary are they
building a bigger better indestructible
Charlie Roe bionic man
yeah well I've got two artificial valves
AHA and I'm not sure what's next but I'm
ready well you're certainly tough as
hell we just we showed this video at the
upfront when we were talking all the
advertiser for CBS this spring we should
get a load of Charlie Rose I got a brand
new ticker son this year you were forced
to take a break for this surgery was
that hard for you it well it was
necessary
so therefore the doctor said you got to
do this so I had a week in the hospital
he did the surgery that's it a week yeah
they cracked the ribs I didn't open it
up and went in there and gave me a new
valve but cow valve
they say bovine valve yeah that's North
Carolina for cows it's it's a cow in you
it is and and the other one is a pig so
I've got a pig and a cow competing to
send blood to my heart I've often
wondered why you start mooing for no
readings now no I did not know that
until watching Stephen last night Moo
and we've talked about surfing Stephen
said are you gonna ask the pig and the
cow and I think we'll hear a Moo Aurum
Oh with you in a speedo I've seen that
it's quite at really tell us when did
you know we got to go to this weekend
right now we gotta go Dora places are
you gonna tell me during the break we
got to go do I get the seat so do I get
to know